dink dink dink
welcome back to the podcast
i am julian here with me today
i have my two small
long rata dogs we have kermit
and we have peach sharing the table with
me
what an honor it is to have you two here
you both have had quite the week and now
uh
well we back back on the podcast and i
know you guys
uh you got a little marble action got a
little marble action last week he hung
out with me
and uh we needed some iggy action this
week especially because of the week
we've had
geez which we'll get into anyway this
episode is brought to you by
post mates postmates is a proud sponsor
of the podcast guys if you want food
delivered do it with postmates all right
it is a great way to support local
businesses in your community
as well and they have contact free
delivery so you can be totally safe
right now
download the postmates app and use code
jenna julian for 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days of using the app
and get munching and crunching on that
food
also guys me undies world's softest
undies
coming in whatever uh classic or fun
color
prints that you like uh delivered right
to your door three times softer than
cotton go to meundies.com
jenna julian that's meundies.com and
julian get 15
off your first order free shipping and
100 satisfaction guarantee that means
you will be 100
satisfied and they guarantee it
anyway welcome back to the podcast uh
i'm excited to be here
once again hanging out with you guys and
uh chatting
chatting it up um
i honestly can't tell you how excited i
am to have both kermit and peach
happy and well laying right in front of
me right now it's uh
it's been uh quite a long week uh
probably a few of you
know about it uh at least
for peachy peachy had uh
had a crazy week uh
but rewinding before that um
[Music]
kermit so yeah the first half of this
podcast i just wanted to kind of give
you an update on
the dogs really uh and me too a little
bit but mainly the dogs
uh considering you know there's some
stuff i wanted to update you on they're
all okay and fine and happy
but i do want to i want to share some
stuff with you
and then the second half of the podcast
um i got suggested an idea on twitter i
believe it was willowis who
uh thought it'd be cool to talk about
tattoos we could talk tattoos for a
little bit i could look at some of your
tattoos that you submitted
into our discord we have a tattoo
channel uh so i was
sitting there completely oohing over all
of your ink i mean
the dink fam is so so tatted up
i had no idea and you guys have the
coolest tattoos i
there's literally not enough podcasts
that i could
go through all of them but i i wanted to
and i looked at a lot more than i'll be
showing on on the episode today
so if you submitted and you didn't get
on the episode just know that i probably
looked at it and
my jaw dropped um in private okay even
though it wasn't the episode
also i'm gonna do my very best at
uh minding our audio listeners because i
don't want to just be looking at a photo
and being like hey this photo is cool
moving on because if you're listening to
that uh
well that's just a bit shitty um
so i do want to be mindful that dude you
know there are people that
don't watch this on youtube and they
listen to it
on their commute and they don't have
visuals so i'm going to do my best at
when i'm looking at the photos or
talking about
my tattoos or whatever i'll describe
them i will be as uh
descriptive and you know colorful
in my language as possible in a good way
and a bad way
so you guys can get a good uh image of
what's going on
anyway uh
long story short peachy here
had to be hospitalized uh last week
and she's fine now she is okay she is
happy and healthy and back home
um kermit incidentally also went to the
same
hospital i don't think
i would classify him as being
hospitalized the only reason he went to
that same hospital
was because it was after hours of our
vet it was it was a vet
level of visit right like we would have
taken him to our vet
but it was after hours and he was in
kind of a good amount of pain so we
brought him to the hospital
peachy actually had to be admitted for
an overnight stay that was full-on
hospitalization uh for peachy
one of my worst days ever so long story
long
um peachy was
uh showing signs of like you know an
upset stomach she was throwing up it was
kind of coming out both ends and she was
she was just kind of like not herself
she was shivering
um there's it's weird because like the
night before
we brought her in i'm streaming
and she like looks at me from her bed
her bed is on my desk while i stream
and she looks at me from her bed and
like wants to get picked up and she
never does that she always loves sitting
in her bed so i pick her up and i hold
her and she's just like shivering
and i remember thinking i was like man
something feels wrong like
i don't know what it is you know she
doesn't really ever do this so i let her
outside thinking you know she really had
to go to the bathroom
she came back and really just wanted to
sit with me uh and so throughout that
that night overnight throughout the
evening while i was sleeping i would
wake up
uh we would both wake up and kind of
hear her going to the bathroom to throw
up and
struggle to go to the bathroom and in
the morning that continued she was
pretty relentlessly throwing up and
it was to the point where i was very
concerned so i
uh i was very
what's the word i was very uh insistent
that
she gets seen i called the vet and i
said i i don't know if you have
appointments today but i need my dog to
get seen
and this was like at 7am i'm on the
phone because i woke up early because
she was
kept getting out of bed and i've just
been waking up early anyway but
i took her in at about 7 30
and she i dropped her off and they call
me a few hours later i want to say like
two and a half hours later saying
um basically that she's continued to
throw up at the vet she's like
continue to exhibit signs she's okay
we took her blood and things look okay
we think she might have
um
what am i blanking on it now um
the blood test for
i'm so blanking on it whatever it was
something with her stomach
um something itis oh
i don't know why i'll think of it later
but anyway this came back as a positive
she was like yeah we think she might
have this
uh and it's not appendicitis it's the
other one it's uh
it's uh jesus what is wrong with me
it's been a long week anyway so they're
like yeah she's okay she's stable
we took her blood you know we think she
has this but we do recommend
that you pick her up and bring her to
the hospital
and the reason we recommend that is
because we think that with her condition
she might want to be monitored overnight
it might be a good idea to not have her
be
at home tonight it might be a good idea
to have her be under supervision while
the night goes through just because we
don't know if it's going to get worse we
don't know how she's going to be
um and so we were like of course i was
like i'm on my way i
flew over there to the vet grabbed her
drove her right to the hospital
dropped her off and i'm holding her
and i'm you know i'm standing on the
sidewalk you can't go into the vet
these days because uh you know there's
you drop
you pull up and they come out and they
take your pet
and so i'm holding her and i'm looking
at her i'm like you know
nothing really is going through my brain
i'm just like dropping my dog off at the
vet i didn't really
feel like it was a situation where i
needed to be
concerned in any way even though i'm at
the hospital like i only
felt like i was there for precautionary
reasons and
so they take her and
i head home and about an hour later they
call me
which i feel like uh if you if you have
a pet and you
have been to the vet multiple times you
kind of know that like
and they will tell you this but you kind
of know that no no news is good news
when they when your dog is in their
hands the less they call you the better
in a way at least generally so getting a
call like
i think even less than an hour after i
dropped her off i was like okay what is
this
so she uh she tells me it's the vet tech
and she's like hey
or it might have even been the doctor
she was like hey
uh peachy's with us she's okay um
she's still throwing up she's a bit cold
and we can't get her blood pressure
and i'm like wait what does that even
mean i said what what do you mean you
can't get her blood pressure what does
that mean
and she was like well it's too low so we
can't our machine isn't even reading it
and i'm like i just remember feeling
like
all of a sudden i just went cold i was
like okay um
okay and they're like well okay so
because because of this we are
we're marking her care critical and i'm
like okay
and they're like we'll keep you updated
and that was the phone call so i was
like
pretty obviously worried at that point
and it was it wasn't fun
uh i don't think anyone really
ever wants to hear that on the phone
when when in regards to their pet
it's just like a scary thing and it
sucks especially because it really felt
like from the moment i dropped her
both at the vet that morning and at the
hospital that afternoon
from both of those moments it went from
that to 100
real quick and i didn't feel like i was
ready for that at all there was no
warning there was no
sense of this could be a bad day in my
mind it just kind of like escalated
really fast with that phone call
so that was really rough and uh the
afternoon was very
very long i
sat around i tried to keep it together i
couldn't focus on anything i couldn't
get lost in any activity i was pretty
much just like mentally or physically or
both pacing
through my house and my brain for the
better part of that day
until the late afternoon early evening
finally spoke to the doctor and she
reassures me
she's improving peach his blood pressure
is now reading she's warming up
she took a nap she is no longer throwing
up
she's responding to the anti-nausea
and the fluids they had her on heavy
fluids because she was very very
dehydrated at that point
and from that from that point on it was
it was just kind of up and up and up and
it got better and better
and she stayed overnight and uh then i
picked her up the next morning oh
afternoon actually she was there for all
the next morning
picked her up the next afternoon uh and
when i
when i saw her i i burst into tears and
i couldn't believe i still could get to
see her because part of me thought i was
never gonna see her again
and that um it was gnarly it was it was
like a weird
random very unexpected
couple of days for me and i'm assuming
even worse for her
but she's healthy and happy she had what
they called acute
gastroenteritis to the point where
something triggered it
and it basically caused a whole slew of
issues with her
uh and i don't want to go too much into
it because it would just be like me
reading symptoms of an ailment that a
dog went through it's not interesting
but she
she was going through it and um we're
changing her diet to a low-fat diet
moving forward
um she's on some medication for a little
while and we have to really keep an eye
on her and not let her be a scavenger
like she likes to be
uh but she is she's okay and she's
healthy and back in our house and
uh it was just it was like one of those
weird life reminders that like
[ __ ] can just be not can just be
you know [ __ ] is just totally random
and the moment you think that things
have to make sense for them to happen to
you
is the moment something completely
nonsensical and random happens to you
where you struggle and struggle and
struggle to try to understand why it's
happening
or to come to terms with it um and then
after it's done whether it ends good
like it did for me fortunately
thank god or if it ends in tragedy you
are thinking about it for a long time
and
wondering why it happened and then
you're just faced with the cold reality
that
sometimes life is just [ __ ] random
and
when it when it comes to sickness and
even death
you know things like that not to get too
dark and stuff but it's just that you
know there is
there's no rhyme or reason sometimes to
things that happen
um and that's really hard and so it was
a hard week but i'm
i can't even tell you how happy i am to
have her back home
and she's doing so well and
just hug your pets you know what i mean
you never know
what weird little thing might pop up and
scare you half to death that you'll
never see him again
so that is what happened to peach um
i'm gonna move on on a lighter note and
talk about what happened to kermit
because it was very
very mild in comparison uh
kermit i mean it's not mild in the sense
that it's nothing because
you know as much as we joke that he's
our he is our uh
disaster child he's always at the vet
he's always stepping on bees and whatnot
you know he's he's an old man he's 10
and he's dealing with
you know older dog ailments now and he
was in pain
so it wasn't funny obviously but in
comparison it is much lighter
kermit had to be brought into the vet a
few days prior to this whole peach
situation
uh because he was he was crying a lot
when we would pick him up he was yelping
he couldn't really move that well and we
actually started to notice a physical
swelling in his side not not like a ball
or anything like a cute but it was just
like a general overall
his like ribs and stomach looked a
little like you know inflamed i don't
really know
uh but it was enough for us to be like
well let's take him into the you know
the hospital because again it was like
after hours and it was we didn't
have time to make an appointment we had
to just take him in
so he brought him in and uh
at first they looked at him they were
like okay nothing left
nothing life-threatening you know we
looked at him we palpated him he's he's
okay
uh we're going to send him home and if
he gets worse or it doesn't improve
bring him back and we'll get an x-ray
didn't improve later that night later in
the evening we brought him back for an
x-ray
they did an x-ray and uh we basically
learned that he
is suffering from something called ivd
disease
which stands for intervertebral disc
disease
which basically um from what i
understand means that the little discs
in between his vertebrae the little
bones that make up his vertebrae
in between those there are something
called discs and
the way they explain it to us which i'll
use the analogy i don't know if it'll be
helpful is that
the bones have these little jelly donuts
in between them right to pad
each other from bumping into each each
other's you know each other bones
and so the jelly donuts are very
important in that they protect
bones from each other they protect the
overall
integrity of the spine and when
the bones compress on that jelly donut
and the disc
goes up into the spinal cord it can
cause a whole bunch of problems
on the minor side it can cause pain um
discomfort lack of you know you know
limited movement
on the more serious side it can cause
like very
traumatizing things like paralysis it
can paralyze a dog it can cause nerve
pain
uh can cause nerve damage all sorts of
stuff because the spinal cord obviously
is very important
so we learned that you know basically
kermit has ibd disease
and it's like old man back disease and
we
have to put him on crate rest and so
for the past week he has been on what we
like to call around the house carry me
disease
which he is absolutely not upset about
uh but he doesn't get free reign to walk
or run around at all anymore we carry
him pretty much everywhere
the only time he sees the ground uh is
when he needs to use
the bathroom outside or eat his food the
rest of the time he's either in a crate
or in our sling that we have that we go
throw over our shoulder or in his bed on
our desk
so the iggys are
i guess you could say the eggs are a bit
out of commission
at the time being but um they're okay
um like i said you know it was a
it was not a fun week but we're just
we're
very very happy to have both of them
home with us and feeling better and
they're all on medication kermit's on
something they call medical
management which is cray rest it's like
you do a bunch of things to try to limit
their movement and hopefully by doing
those things you're
treating his pain indirectly
hello
uh so
that is the update on the dogs hopefully
uh you uh
you're not wondering anymore what
happened or whatever but um
again just counting my lucky stars and
feeling very grateful that both of them
are in good health and okay
i'm gonna put you back on this
bed here because i don't want to carry
you well i podcast um
so on top of the the fact that the dogs
were uh going through this week i
actually took a little trip to
joshua tree i went out to
joshua tree to film something
that you will be seeing tomorrow on my
personal channel it's a video that i've
been working on all week
i actually went out of town after all of
the dog drama happened obviously
and i went out for one day stayed at an
airbnb
completely isolated and filmed a video
out there i think it was a really fun
video idea and i'm excited for you guys
to see it
um i'm not gonna say anything about it
but it was a
it was a cool video and i got to isolate
myself somewhere other than my house
which felt actually pretty good honestly
just getting outside looking at
the the scenery that's not my house or
my neighborhood
was just like was really nice um also it
was fun to like shoot a proper whole
entire video with a little bit of travel
mixed in it was something i missed
haven't done in a very long time and um
i
i definitely enjoyed doing that so if
you're looking forward to
videos like that check my channel
tomorrow tomorrow morning it'll be out
and uh the whole time it was very hot
very hot like 107 to 110 most of the day
only cool down when the sun completely
disappeared but luckily i had my me
undies
to keep me nice and cool three three
times softer than cotton
and just silky smooth and breathable
perfect for
any temperature right now you guys can
get your mandy's too
you can go to meundies.com and julian
start saving 15
with free shipping and satisfaction
guaranteed and what you can do is you
can shop for an individual pair
you can shop for a onesie very light and
breathable onesies you can try for
broadlets
you can shop for socks they have a lot
of different options if you're shopping
for soft things okay
we like to call the uh the onesie the
outfit of the quarantine because i feel
like it is perfect to wear around your
house it's a gamer outfit you guys know
this
uh and they also offer
a me undies membership where you would
get
new uh items every month delivered to
you
and you don't have to pick them out
which is cool um they're serious about
softness
like so serious that they secured the
world sorry they scott
they scoured the world for the softest
fabric known to man we have been talking
about house author fabric is for years
now
three times softer than cotton it is
micro modal
and it's really hard to describe because
once you feel it you just kind of get it
uh it all starts with sustainably
sourced beechwood trees that magically
turn from pulp to yarn to undies
undies that feel kind of like heaven on
your skin it's basically like being
naked without being naked
so check it out go to meundies.com jenna
julian it's a no-brainer you get 15 off
your first order and
free shipping with 100 satisfaction
awesome sponsor of the podcast
also post mates we use this all the time
it is a great delivery service it makes
it easy
for you to enjoy all the food you love
without any of the hassle or
risk now of going to get it out in the
world a lot of
your areas are only doing takeout which
is perfect for postmates because
postmates is still bringing you all
the food that you like and you can eat
it in the safety and comfort of your own
home
they also have postmates pickup which
you can use to
basically use takeout but they the
process of doing it on postmates is so
much easier than having to like call
look up a menu online no postmates has
it all right here for you so if you do
feel like going to get take takeaway
yourself
you use postmates pickup it's a great
way like i said ordering local to
support your local
businesses and restaurants that you
might love and might be struggling right
now
just download postmates on ios or
android
and find your favorite foods you can
even go grocery shopping on post mates i
do it all the time even if it's one
ingredient or 10 ingredients or 50
ingredients you can
do your shopping on post mates for food
any which way
download the postmates app use code
jenna julian that's a hundred dollars of
free delivery credit you'll get for your
first seven days of using the app
it is a very very cool app and makes
life easy
in a time when life is hard it's very
important
very very important
so i thought it would be fun after
reading willow's uh
comment on twitter that we go over some
tattoos and
uh i get to look at some of your tattoos
and i guess
um i could also talk a little bit about
my tattoos first or maybe i'll do that
after
let's go to your tattoos my tattoos
you've seen you know what i mean maybe
i'll
give you a little bit of a a tour or
whatnot
after i go through yours but i do want
to
note sorry i'm just messing with this i
do want to note
i'm going to move to the side so you can
see him uh that i
will only be positively
critiquing and looking commenting rather
not critiquing positively commenting on
your podcast
on your tattoos on the podcast excuse me
because i do feel like tattoos are not
only so
personal and important to each person
that has them but
it is nobody's business in general my
opinion it is nobody's business
to critique someone else's tattoos at
least out loud keep it to yourself hey
peach i love you but you need to stay
there
stay stay um
i i am so overwhelmed by how beautiful
all of your tattoos are and all of you
should should be
so excited and proud to have these
amazing pieces of art on your body
forever
and whether if whether they mean nothing
to you in terms of like an event or a
person or a memory or they mean
something really important to you
it's it's important in its own right
just because it's your tattoo so i think
it's important that
we all mind that uh just in general you
know when when looking at other people's
tattoos just
be nice and always put yourself in the
position of someone who might be
receiving the feedback of something that
is so personal to them
you know what i mean it's it's a very
personal thing so let's just all be
let's all be good anyway let's start by
the way i i think i mentioned earlier
but um
bubs is the first one we'll look at uh
this is the discord i'm reading from
okay so if you want to please post your
tattoos
in the tattoo channel of our discord you
can find our discord in the link below
bubs
first of all bubs i'm so incredibly
sorry for your loss this is a really
really
heavy uh thing that you are going
through
my sister was killed in car accident
last wednesday night we had matching
tattoos
that she had done she was a tattoo
artist
last night i had her boss at the shop
give me her half of the set so they
could stay together forever i'm in love
with it
bubs i am so incredibly sorry for your
loss sending you so much love this
tattoo is beautiful
um it seems well first of all it's
the color is just it pops so well
i love the symmetry of it i love the
meaning behind it and i love how
you got both sides to it um
just adorable i love it just a really
really really sweet
beautiful tattoo that clearly means a
lot to you and again i'm sorry for your
loss
and i hope you're doing okay uh sir
rosie
or rosa i have one on my arm so this
doesn't have a description
but i'm looking at some nice line work
of a woman
with like a cloud covering her face
which is really neat
uh and she seems to be like in water
like based on i love it i love
the mix between just the fine lines and
the dots
because it's like a beautiful contrast
of uh of the two
kind of line works i think that's really
neat
kermit's crying already kermit do you
want tattoos
uh wolf andy arrow
oh no sorry they were they were replying
to wolf handiero uh g-e-q-c-e
says these are my two most recent and
then they posted two
one of this long big snake and then one
of
a big old bird i'm looking at the bird
one it looks to be on their thigh
this is outstanding i can't believe it's
like they're the top of their thigh
their quad is covered by
uh hawk eagle looking bird just really
majestic
all black and gray with some flowers
behind them and in front of him
i love the fact that you can
like bring such
i don't know emotion to a tattoo with no
color like that's one of my favorite
things about black and gray tattoos is
they
they are so strong and how they feel and
they don't even
need the color to um to kind of bring
that
intensity but this is so beautiful
really well done
it's also also a really cool spot to
have a big old tattoo on the top of your
quad
like what a cool you see that thing all
the time
people see it it's like right there i
love tattoos that you just like they're
right there for you
all right bobert posted a cute little
cactus it's like a cactus in a pot
my artist called me his cactus boy and
the cactus
has a balloon floating above it and
behind it almost looks like
oh it is okay the the cactus is like has
its arm wrapped around
the balloon it's a red balloon and green
cactus i love this because it's
it's just such a beautiful contrast of
color and it's simple
it's just a terra cotta pot with some
brown a cactus with a few shades of
green and a balloon with red
it's just simple and beautiful and it
like it sits completely well by itself
and that could be its own piece on your
arm forever
or you could you know
have it join an entire sleeve and it
would work just as well i love that
i totally love that uh it's ah satan
posted finnish tattoo today if anyone
knows eat your kimchi
their their saying is to build a ladder
and it's inspired by this tattoo
uh i don't know that but this is
incredible this
is honestly this actually reminds me of
my artist who has done all my color work
anna in that this sort of looks a little
bit like watercolor
it's so beautiful and vibrant and the
strokes
on both the flowers and the ladder
there's like a ladder surrounded by
these really beautiful flowers
um the strokes and the way the strokes
look almost look
look as if they're done by a paintbrush
and not a tattoo gun
which i i'm always mesmerized when
artists can pull that off and make
hey you have to stay i can't hold two
dogs okay peachy sits
thank you baby i'm always mesmerized
when uh tattooers can make it feel like
you're looking at a painting and not a
tattoo
so cool jessa with the reaper woman
oh my dude i heavily [ __ ] with this one
so it's this woman holding a reaper
and her outfit is all black she's
wearing a hood that's covering half of
her face
she has a tattoo of a little skull on
her shoulder
and then also has a skull as part of her
hood
with two beautiful looks like roses
behind her
in love with this one i big time [ __ ]
with this one i
i don't know what it is about like oh
and then her in the middle of her gown
there's like a tree
happening so neat i love
dark tattoos that
have this like i love the reaper i love
the skulls i love all of it the vibe of
this is something that i just like
really [ __ ] with i really like this a
lot
and i can see why you would want this it
looks like a
calf i think it's a calf tattoo very
very cool jessa
willow gotta throw my little buddy in
there willow i think you might have put
in a few
a few suggestions or not suggestions
though but a few of your tattoos
and this is the one i picked but it's a
little cat
very thin fine line work of a cat laying
on its back with its belly showing and
the tail coming out the bottom
and on its belly it says in very simple
print all caps me
time i love this one
this one is really cute i love how
simple it is but it's also like
very much a vibe and it does a good job
of uh
with its little information because it's
not a complicated tattoo but it does a
good job with what is there
really conveying what what the mood is
and i love that the eyes i don't know
it's just
neat i love stuff like that
uh mckaylan coming in hot
just so hot with a dink fam
dink juice tattoo with bright colors
our dink logo the word dink and a straw
it's actually one of our emotes
um very very cool i love this mchalen
i also do know that there was a fair a
fair few of um
pinup tattoos of me as summer and i have
seen a lot of them
i didn't choose any for this episode but
i have seen a few of them
and they are special so if you decided
to get me as a pin-up doll
dressed as summer on your body
i first of all want to thank you and
honor you
and second of all why don't you lay down
baby
second of all i want to applaud you
because that's uh brave
and um well i don't know if i would get
a tattoo of me because i don't
i don't want to look at me that much
uh we got mo molly coming in with this
really really colorful yet dark piece
i love it it's it okay so it has like a
samurai vibe to it so
peach you can't you can't do that you
little there's audio equipment on the
table she's like digging on the table
baby this is a cuddle cup it's not a
blanket
sit sit baby sit i'll tuck you in if you
sit
sorry about this peachy you gotta sit
baby you gotta sit okay
it's a wave this is a cuddle cup so
there's not like a blanket
she can get tucked in she's like why i
don't understand i just want to be under
it
you can you want to sit on your okay
here
all right that's where you're going to
be anyway this tattoo okay
from mo molly it's uh like a black
diamond
and then on top of it is a purple
butterfly
and the the butterfly has a has a design
on its wings where there are eyes on
each wing so there's four total eyes
because there's like the upper right
lower right upper left lower left
and the eyes have this yellow tint
similar to the yellow on the back
of the butterfly and also the yellow
that's on
the diamond shape that has sort of a
samurai vibe
i love this i [ __ ] love this i would
love to know more about this tattoo and
what
what inspired it but just looking at it
is like one of those tattoos that
it just looks freaking cool it just
looks cool
you know eclarin
this one caught my eye because
of the simplicity and the color and how
it works together so this is uh
it's color but it's also black and gray
there's like a mountain range
all in black and then above it there's a
dragon all
in red with no black on it so it's just
a complete red
line work tattoo with a little
red marking on the mountain to contrast
but
something about just the plain red line
work next to the plain black line work
really works for me i love the shading
of the mountain
i think it has enough depth while also
being very simplistic and neat
um and the red i mean both with the
dragon and the marking on the mountain
really makes it pop
and i think it's kind of nice
uh christy 182 ava
posted all of her tattoos but i picked
the first one plus i have a little paw
print with an orange heart connected for
one of my cat
so this is just one i picked this is
really neat because it's
very bright and in a cool spot it's like
on the shoulder like right here
i've seen a lot of cool tattoos on like
near the collarbone i've actually [ __ ]
with the idea of maybe getting one
like maybe something right here because
i think it's just a neat spot but this
looks like a sunflower and it's just
really
popping with the color and i love
tattoos that are just super visible
both because they're vibrant color but
also their placement i think those are
just awesome
so this one's really cool christy
silly love seeing all these beautiful
pieces here's my most recent tattoo it's
a bob ross inspired landscape
with my favorite quote of his underneath
as long as you're learning
you're not failing first of all great
quote
this tattoo just has a real
classic vibe it's just got a it's got a
vibe to it that's like
no matter what like trends of tattoo
come and go this tattoo will always be
[ __ ] cool
i mean bob ross like you can't go wrong
it's a bob ross painting
of a mountain trees lake and sunset just
beautiful the colors pop
it's got that watercolor brush vibe to
it
and the lettering is really nice
lettering is hard
and this lettering is really nice
i really really like this one
uh aim media study girl tattoo that
wasn't meant to be a study girl but
definitely turned out to be a study girl
i like this one a lot this one is uh
this is very very basic clean
like well done line work right just fine
line
sing almost single needle i don't
actually know of a single needle but
it's just one of those like very
straightforward linework tattoos
it looks like a person in front of their
window and then behind them
through the window you see their cat
perched up on the windowsill
and you see the moon and some stars
and it's just all done with just like
almost one line
so simple i love tattoos that are just
doesn't need a lot to like really
portray a vibe this looks like
i get a whole entire vibe from this
tattoo i can hear the rain
i can feel the the sense of
being alone and having your cat with you
there and
just the whole thing i just love it
sarah head my two favorite out of all my
tattoos the skull relates more to my
studies in radiology
i love that you're studying radiology
and you have a skull i think that's
badass
um slash radiation therapy and then the
bike is for my gpa
oh my grandpa i'm so sorry my grandpa
who recently passed away even at the age
of 87 was riding his bike around town
okay the bike tattoo is what caught my
eye i'm gonna rotate it so i can see it
better
but the bike tattoo is so so
so neat um i'm sorry for your loss
sounded like your grandpa was awesome
and so cool that
he was riding his bike around town even
at 87.
this actually was done in one line this
is a single
line tattoo and it starts with the front
wheel
and goes through and does the whole
how do you even do this it's all done
with one line
it's like makes the wheel goes around
makes the handlebar
makes the seat and then the other wheel
and then it's all done it's all one line
it's literally one stroke that is so
neat
oh man very cool sarah i'm sorry to hear
about euro lawson very cool tattoo
micro nerd getting a disney tattoo for
my family stitch
is for me the minion is for my brother i
still need to get
baloo mulan and lady got the tribal
dolphin when i turned 18.
so this one caught my eye because it's
like so much so much color on such a big
tattoo this is covering their entire
calf
and like the back and the front almost
of their calf like it covers their whole
leg
that to me is just so cool
the purple the purple and the yellow how
do you get those colors to like pop so
well
i don't know man that is so badass the
minion looks cool
oh man i love it very cool tattoos
um and i love stitch too i've seen a lot
of stitch tattoos this is very very cool
the colors are definitely what caught my
eye on that one though
okay there's an aries tattoo of an aries
ram done by annoying flowers had to
shout that one out that one looks super
dope
uh and then this one what is this this
is crazy
uh consensual consensuals i got this
when i was 17
in this guy's house for 300 and it took
five hours okay
circumstantial circumstantially it
doesn't sound like something i would do
but it turned out so cool i've never
gotten a tattoo in someone's house
yeah i've never no i've never done that
uh also
is that allowed at 17 anyway it's dope
doesn't matter
i don't know what this is or what it's
inspired by
but it's bad [ __ ] ass it looks like
maybe an anime
i don't know the red the black and the
silver
again also a leg tattoo i'm a big fan of
leg tattoos
i think this looks really really neat
uh kim kitsune tattoo with sunflowers on
my ankle
by mellie mae on ig she deserves so much
more love her tattoos are amazing
mellie mae i'm gonna dude i'm gonna drop
the follow real quick
let's dig instagram out of the depths of
my phone
meli may
m-e-l-l-y-y-m-a-e
follow dunzo this tattoo is insanely
cool
it's like a a cat mask it almost looks
like a japanese cat mask
with all black and gray except for the
designs on the cat mask are red and the
red pops
so well the line work is pretty damn
impeccable
the shading is so nice and simple and
there's like a rope
and some flowers i would get this tattoo
i don't even know what it means and i
would get it
so so so cool love this
uh super cat 202 this is my newest
largest and favorite tattoo currently
i've got a few others
and i'm super excited to be getting one
from anna when the warren tattoo opens
again yes
dude so anna again is my artist who's
done all my color work on my arm
she's wonderful her name's aniko jakari
and her tattoo shop the warren actually
closed down
temporarily due to kovid they have to
relocate and it's
one of the many businesses that have
been affected by what's going on
so yeah like definitely hope they can
find a spot and open back up soon
um holy [ __ ] this tattoo super cat holy
[ __ ]
dude
i couldn't believe this tattoo when i
saw it
it's a lion with this like blue color
hue to it but like super realistic hyper
realistic i want to say
with two really vibrant yellow flowers
next to it
and it looks like some berries on the
flowers
and i can't tell is are those berries on
the head or is that like a bow tie
no i think those are berries oh it's so
cool i
like this is one of those tattoos that
you're like scrolling and you see it and
you have to like stop and like zoom in
and inspect every little piece of it
because it's just so incredible
the the the lion tattoo
i feel like is just so hard because of
all the intricacies of the hair that
come with
the both of the face and the facial
expression but then also like the mane
of a lion and this is just so beautiful
the hair is like flowy and it's detailed
but not too detailed to the point where
it takes away from like the softness of
it
oh such a fan of this one big big fan of
this one
seth hi dink fam here's my most recent
tattoo a deer skull with magnolias
i'm a sucker for skull tattoos of any
kind deer skulls human skulls
cat skulls i have a a cat skull on me
this is uh wow
this is just so beautiful i love it
it's simple i love a simple black and
gray skull tattoo i'm honestly a simple
i'm a simple person in that way
i think it's just real nice and uh
the magnolias add a lot to it and i
think it's uh
really really sweet so oh and there's
also a touch of white on there too
you can see there's like some white dots
and line work throughout to highlight
which i think is
uh so so cool
and i got two three more i got three
more okay the
first one is from kaisi kaizee my two
main tattoos
uh dogs just because i like
them and kat is to honor my baby who i
had for 18 years so i picked the dog one
because it just caught me but this is
so cool it's simple there's like a
there's like a chain that comes from
behind them and comes out in front of
them
and then there's two i'm blanking on the
name of this breed but it's a very
common not common it's a very well-known
breed i'm stupid for not knowing
it um
i'm going to say the wrong breed and
then get laughed at so i'm not going to
say a breed but it's really beautiful
and your dogs look amazing in it
i love the saturation of black versus
the lack of
color on the chain so it makes the dogs
really pop out
really really neat uh wicked normal
coming in hot with a cover up i wouldn't
even
even been able to know to be honest it's
from a doctor who episode
vincent and the doctor has gotten me
through the toughest of times
i have it on my forearm so i'm always
always know i'm not alone this is
beautiful i love the story behind it
i feel like the color and the black just
works so well together on this tattoo
it's a it looks like a police phone
booth or a police box
phone booth with it's all black and it
looks
almost done like with splatter paint
it's just so cool and then there's just
this really bright
blue and yellow smoke and hue behind it
that contrasts the black so well
big big fan of this one never watched
doctor who a day in my life
still a very very very rad tattoo that i
personally love
anyway and then we got lore
lores hayes i'm so late but i have a
thigh tattoo bigger than my hand i would
love to show it but i'm sure i'd have to
censor it
since it includes a blank uh
peen the tattoo has a peen because he's
naked
he's lovely he's just naked and so they
did include
the entire tattoo and just censored out
the pain
but this is such a badass tattoo dude
uh i don't really know
the story behind it and nor do i need to
it is just
so neat i'm a sucker for like i said
like dark vibe black and gray tattoos
i don't know why they always get me i
just love this and i think this is just
beautiful artwork i have nothing but
good things to say about this tattoo
it's very very cool
very cool anyway okay so those are the
tattoos that you guys sent in and that i
wanted to kerman i'm gonna put you on
the bed now
you gotta lay down lay down okay good
boy
so thank you guys for submitting them uh
i wanted to those are the tattoos i
wanted to go through and just kind of
highlight on the podcast because i
thought
what a fun idea to go through tattoos
and uh talk about them
and uh you guys
you know get a chance for for other
people on the internet to see your
tattoos because we're talking about i
think that's really rad
so first of all thank you to everyone
who submitted
tattoos in the discord and continue to
because i on my free time
definitely all the time go in there
because i just love looking at tattoos
and i think they're really really rad
and i think you guys are all red
and i think your tattoos are very cool
and i'm jealous of all of them and i
want all of them
uh you i've been asked
quite a few times over the years to do
um
like a tattoo tour and
i haven't really done one i haven't
really made a dedicated video or post or
whatever about all my tattoos because i
do feel like it's a bit
first of all i feel like it's a bit vain
so it's like it's hard for me to want to
just be like hey look at all of
my tattoos um
also i did a photo shoot with inked
magazine a few months back
at the beginning of the year actually uh
and i
when that came out that ended up being
more of just like a focus on a couple
wide pictures of me uh with my tattoos
showing
uh rather than like a detailed
journaling of all my tattoos not that
that's what i thought it was gonna be
but i was um you know i was saying to
people like maybe wait till this comes
down you'll see all my tattoos
turns out you won't you can't see all of
my tattoos in that it's a very cool
article and i got to work with an
awesome photographer
um in making that article and that photo
should happen
so i if you haven't checked that out
check it out it's awesome you can just
like search julian
inks magazine but um
i could go over some of my tattoos i
guess right i have so i have
i lost count i have one on my ribs that
i got first this is my first tattoo
it's a date that corresponds to the date
that uh
my brother actually got better from
something that was very serious
my brother had guillain-barre syndrome
um
very long time ago and it was very
serious and it got him to a very very
scary point
uh and he recovered and the tattoo was
to remember how strong he was
and how just amazingly grateful i am to
have him and still have him and
remember what we went through um
then my next tattoo was this little
cloud
on my wrist you guys have seen that
that's very fine line
i got a similar tattoo of the dart for
last minute trips on the other side of
my wrist
same artist daniel winter which was um
just kind of dipping my toes into black
and gray like really fine line tattoos
so i got those two and i'm like yeah you
know
black and gray is cool and then bam got
a whole bunch of color on this arm
uh i made a video about my slurpee
tattoo it was for
my friend brandon who passed away the
slurpee was my first tattoo
of color on my body and also my first
tattoo from anna
who is amazing and incredible and i
can't wait to work with her again
um and by work with her i mean sit like
a sweaty slob while she performs her
incredible artwork on me that i get to
have for the rest of my life
i loved it so much that i just kept
going back to her over and over and over
and i
have since filled i would say like a
two-thirds sleeve
of my left arm in her work and i've
dedicated my whole arm to
you know i've given my arm to her we did
a forearm piece that took nine hours
of where the wild things are with a
little bit of a dia de los muertos
kind of spin at least with there was a
little bit of skelly action
but the colors i'm just in love with i
have an iron giant
one of my favorite movies growing up i
actually got that tattooed
on my arm at a tattoo convention which
was an interesting experience
from anna then i have buttercup the cow
uh a wonderful cow that i got to know
for a little while who passed away
and i have a desert
uh new mexico scene
behind with a hot air balloon and some
sunset and then on top i have
my bunny my bun bun foof right here
this is my last big color tattoo and
i have this big old empty space right
here on the inside of my arm so i'm
excited to fill that
when i get tattoos again on this side i
have the uh i have the saber tooth
cat fossil which is the official it's
the official fossil
which i didn't know states have official
fossils is the official fossil
of california so this saber-toothed cat
right here is is like a ode to
california me growing up here
this skull right here i did not design
but i composed based on
other designs that i had found and kind
of altered a little bit
uh and there is i i changed it in that
there used to be a bunch of flowers and
instead
i changed it to wheat
plant the wheat flour because i cannot
have wheat and this is a skull and the
skull is dead and if i eat wheat
i will die even though that's not true
but um it's almost like it's my
kryptonite and i cannot have it so i
decided to mix it into a cool little um
skull arrangement you know to remember
that this guy can have it but i can't
i also have this tv man a man wearing
the suit with a tv for a head
this was actually um a piece of art on
my tattoo artist's wall
jason stores in venice one of my
favorite tattoo
artists that i've ever gotten to work
with i can't wait to go back to him
really awesome dude very very talented
he had this piece on a canvas on his
wall and i was getting tattooed and i
said
that is a really cool piece and he said
thanks my friend drew it and i said
can i have it on my body and he was like
yeah
and so the way we did it uh and that's
just one of those instances where i just
i see something um in in like an
artistic set setting and i just love it
so much that i
want it as part of my collection i'm a
collector you know what i mean and i
thought it was like a very
very um captivating style of tattoo i
could relate it to myself a little bit
because the guy
has the tv for a head so i kind of think
of that as like
you know i'm on people's screens right
not tvs but i'm on their screens and
that's sort of
is one part of me and this tattoo can
kind of represent that part of me in a
way
i have my kitchen tools on my outer
forum from louis perez
one another one of my favorite tattoo
artists he's really rad dude
i got to work with him when i shot
something for inked magazine a few years
ago
he actually gave me this little iggy
right here
uh or greyhound just kind of a generic
greyhound tattoo for the dart
dart video where we threw a dart at a
flash sheet of tattoos
and whatever it landed on we would get
louie was the artist we were blessed to
have him there
uh i i immediately was like dude
i'm gonna hit you up and he was like
yeah here's my number and we've been
pals and he's been an awesome artist for
me ever since uh and he did these
awesome kitchen utensils for me
as well i also have my vacuum my
breaking bad
vacuum
hoover max extract pressure pro
model 60 of course i got this
shortly after i got the kitchen utensils
just a fun little vacuum
and then this is i believe my last one
no second last one
this is a viking
with uh wings and a halo above
his head this is for my friend tyler
skaggs who passed away
we were teammates in high school for a
few years
and um the viking is uh because we were
on the vikings that was our team name we
were the vikings santa monica high
school vikings
and the halo is because he was an angel
uh he was on the angels
in the mlb and also because he is an
angel now looking down on us and
11 was the number he had when we were on
the same team and 45 was the number he
had on the angels
and this was done by jason stores easily
one of my most important tattoos and one
that i am just so grateful to have
and i love the way it turned out and
then my last tattoo on my body is a
chair
on my right here
right there it's a chair folding chair
okay
that's it that's my collection oh i also
have a little tree right here too
this is before i got the whole sleeve
so uh i don't know i don't know i had
honestly this is something that uh i
think is a really fun idea i don't know
if the podcast was maybe the perfect way
to do it but i thought that it was good
enough to
to make it happen uh i do think that is
really awesome that you guys were able
to submit so many cool pieces
so many cool pieces for me to choose
from and
um i do think it's really rad to have
a group um like a channel a discord
channel where you can just chat about
tattoos so if you're interested in that
join i and now have to do
uh my duties in carrying the carry me
boy
because that is his medicine i have to
carry him take two of these and
call me when you're done carrying me
i want to say thank you to everyone who
submitted tattoos thank you for watching
and listening
to the podcast i hope you have been
enjoying my solo podcast and um
i'll see you guys next week for another
one remember to keep uh
keep hitting me with your suggestions in
the comments because um
every week i feel like you guys are
awesome and you're
you're thinking of really cool things
for me to do and i appreciate that so
don't stop and i appreciate it
and i will be back for more content
but i hope you had fun doing the tattoo
tours
tattoo tours tattoo tattoo time
i don't know what should we call it
peach what are we calling it
something tattoo but i hope you had fun
doing the tattoo stuff
this week and uh we'll do something else
fun next week uh
and hug your pets be good
have a good monday and i'll see you on
the next podcast
later
[Music]
you